In 2010, the seventh Saw movie was released
and was dubbed as “The Final Chapter”,
and that same year, the creators of the
original Saw, Leigh Whannell and James Wan,
created a new franchise called Insidious. On
the chalkboard in the background of Insidious
is a sketch of a familiar face: Billy the Puppet
from the Saw movies accompanied by the number 8.
This was the first ever clue
about the eighth Saw movie,
which would be released seven
years later and be titled: Jigsaw.
Jigsaw also contains many Easter Eggs of it’s own,
so stick around if you want to hear about them.
Welcome to Things You Missed. I know this is
my third attempt at Things You Missed episode
on Jigsaw, but the first two videos were
made while the movie was still in theaters,
so having the ability to pause and write
down all my notes has given me the time to
notice many more Things You Missed, from the
secrets hidden on computer screens to some
of the oldest franchise staples being reimagined for
a new decade, lets go ahead and get into them.
It opens with the Lionsgate logo, but unlike
many Saw films, this one uses the regular
Lionsgate animation as opposed to the spooky
one. What’s going on here? Did they just forget?
The first actual shot of the movie is
this rolled up mat of tire spikes used
to slow down a fleeing car, but the starburst
shaped image of the spikes also foreshadows
the final scene of the movie, where we get
a nice blooming bouquet of Halloranhead.
The man trying to escape the police is Edgar
Munsen who has been pressured into finding
the trigger that starts the 2016 edition of the
barn game. As he runs, we hear a cinematic cover
of the main theme of the franchise: “Hello Zep”,
with the melody being converted into percussion.
🎵 Chase Edgar - Charlie Clouser 🎵
“Dun du-nuh. Duh, nuh-nuh… nuh-nuh-nuh!
Dun du-nuh. Duh, nuh-nuh… nuh-nuh-nuh!”
He gets to the rooftop and finds the
trigger hidden behind a red X. This
is a callback to the idea of X marks the spot,
which was a clue given by Jigsaw to the
players of his games in Saw and Saw 2.
"X marks the spot."
"What?"
“X marks… marks the spot… for the answer.”
But it would be Saw 2’s X that most closely
relates to the X seen in Jigsaw. In Saw 2,
I discussed how the painting that contains the
X was actually a clue about the movie’s twist,
how the game at the Nerve Gas House
and the police raid of Wilson Steel
Plant could not have taken place at the
same time, because this painting exists
in both locations. We eventually find out
that the Nerve Gas House stuff seen on the
screens was just playback of events that
had already happened many hours before.
Jigsaw uses the same twist, only the game at
the barn takes place many years before the
stuff in the present. It’s unlikely Jigsaw
would use two X markers in the same game,
so when we see a second X on
a tractor later in the movie,
that’s a clue that this game isn’t the
same game as the one in the present.
That may be the most cryptic clue,
but it certainly isn’t the only one.
The movie is actually brimming with
evidence that the barn game we see
is John Kramer’s earliest test game
taking place over a decade before
Halloran begins to investigate the
victim referred to as “buckethead”.
When Jigsaw’s voice comes on for the first
time, we don’t see their facial reactions,
but we can tell that they're scared, as anyone
would be if they were kidnapped. In fact,
they never refer to Jigsaw being their
possible captor, because Jigsaw isn’t even
a known figure at this point. This is before
The Bathroom game or the Razor Wire Trap.
ANNA: “That voice. It said salvation can be
ours if we cleanse our soul of our lies.”
They aren’t even familiar
with the concept of games yet,
because the only trap so far was
Cecil, which was never made public.
CARLY: “He said it was a game.”
ANNA: “Well then I hope for
all of our sakes that it is a game.”
RYAN: “Oh yeah, why is that sweetheart?”
ANNA: “Cause games can be won.”
Everyone acts scared when they see Billy, not
because they recognize him from Jigsaw’s tapes,
but just because he’s creepy on his own.
"No, that's not creepy at all."
When Logan and Eleanor examine the first victim,
there is another clue about the massive time gap.
LOGAN: “The partial decapitation
was made by a circular saw.
Traces of ferric oxide hematite in
the wound.”
ELEANOR: “Rust, from blades.”
When we saw the blades in the first room,
they looked brand new, but after sitting
there for over a decade, it makes sense
that they might have accumulated some rust.
There seems to be a moment in the final
room where Anna recognizes John Kramer,
but she recognizes him as her next door
neighbor, not as the Jigsaw killer.
“Hello Anna.”
“John? John Kramer? ”
Then there’s the issue of the victims themselves.
The first victim, “Buckethead” as they call him,
was Malcolm Neale, who was a criminal that
Halloran failed to convict, so Nelson made
him a part of his imitation version of
John Kramer’s Barn Game. Each player of the
imitation game in 2016 bears a resemblance
to someone from the original game in 2003.
We never see Malcolm Neale’s face, but we do see
the faces of Carly, from 2003 and her counterpart
in 2016 and they are clearly not the same person.
I’m not allowed to show a dead body, but I can
show you credits, where Carly and Carly-look-alike
are played by different actresses.
For some reason, Mitch’s look-alike is
not in the credits, but if you go on IMDb
you can compare the two actors. They
don’t actually look that much alike,
but since we only see Carly and Mitch’s
present day counterparts covered in blood,
it’s a little harder to tell, but you definitely
will notice if you’re looking for it.
It gets a bit convoluted when we find
out that Malcolm Neale’s counterpart
from the past is actually Nelson himself, who
was put in the original barn game for messing
up John Kramer’s X-rays, but was bailed out
because he didn’t wake up in time, resulting
in some deep lacerations on his back, which we
see the scars of in the present day storyline.
And that’s kind of confusing, because he
also put himself in the re-created game,
but his counterpart is Malcolm Neale… not himself.
LOGAN: “Jigsaw put five people in his game. I put
in three. You and I were the last two.”
So Carly’s counterpart is Carly-look-alike,
Mitch’s counterpart is Mitch-look-alike,
Logan Nelson’s counterpart is Malcolm Neale,
Ryan’s counterpart is Logan Nelson, and
Anna’s counterpart is I guess Halloran.
By itself, that might not be enough to
figure it out, but the existence of a
secret game that precedes the Saw saga
is dangled in front of us by Eleanor.
“Supposedly John Kramer designed this trap for
a game that took place before all the others.
They found the plans in his
lab. I built it myself.”
Of course we see that same trap in the barn
game. Then when Eleanor and Logan go into
the barn in the present, you can spot
one of the bucket masks near the door,
and it looks like it’s been
rusting there for years.
So all of that adds up to make Jigsaw’s
twist ending kind of an homage to the
“this game already happened” twist seen
in Saw 2, although I do think it’s more
satisfying in Saw 2 because we find out
the same way the characters find out,
whereas Jigsaw is told out of order just to
trick the audience. But I’ve come to appreciate
it as just being there to honor the history
of the franchise. There would be many other
secrets that pay homage to other aspects
of the Saw movies hidden inside of Jigsaw.
A couple of the supporting characters in
Jigsaw seem to be spiritual successors
to characters from the original series.
Detective Keith Hunt originally appears
to be the new version of SWAT Officer Daniel Rigg,
but we later find out he’s with Internal
Affairs just like Matt Gibson from Saw 7.
There’s also an unnamed Doctor in
Jigsaw who looks like she could
be the sister of Lynn Denlon from Saw
3. Here’s a side by side comparison.
Not sure if this is intentional, I
don’t know how many people do this,
but the doctor is also wearing her watch on
the inside of her wrist, like John Kramer does.
The game itself also shares a ton of
similarities to other traps and games
that we’ve seen in the Saw series, and I think
that because the Barn Game was essentially a
test for Jigsaw before taking his games public,
he would reuse many concepts in his later work.
Let’s look at the first room. There
are many similarities to Saw 5,
the most obvious being that we have five
players with chains around their necks that
are pulling them towards these dangerous blades.
Sixty seconds are given in both scenarios.
JIGSAW: “Today, five will become one, with the common
goal of survival… However if one of you moves
to retrieve the key, the sixty second
timer will begin, for you all.”
Maybe this is a foreshadowing of the fact
that the Barn Game requires the players
to work together, which is also what the
Fatal Five was tasked with figuring out.
“It was meant for five people.”
The final room of their trial asks for a blood
sacrifice, just like the blade room in Jigsaw.
“The device before you is one of
sacrifice. A sacrifice of blood.”
“First, an offering of blood no matter
how little will give you a green light.”
The blood sacrifice is one of many examples
of Jigsaw intentionally making his teachings
have these religious undertones. I’ve
pointed out examples throughout the
Saw Things You Missed episodes, but in
Jigsaw it’s on display more than ever.
Listen to the way John Kramer
addresses his followers.
“Salvation can be yours if you cleanse
yourselves of the habitual lies which
have brought you here... Confess.
The truth will set you free.”
He also speaks not of rehabilitating his victims
like he does during the Saw saga, but he mentions
the need for them to release their demons.
“If you can release yourself from your demons,
you can begin to shoot the chains
that those demons bring with them.”
Previous Saw movies tied into religion because
John’s traps represented the idea of suffering
as a form of repentance for one’s sins,
while Jigsaw focuses more on confession,
which is also what Logan’s final
ultimate plan is for Halloran.
“Innocent people died because of me, I did it!”
The most important part of his revenge
is that he recorded this confession,
and perhaps that is part of the reason that
this movie’s iteration of Billy the Puppet
has the unique glowing red eyes -- a red
light is the universal sign for recording.
I’ve also theorized that it could
be a foreshadowing of what happens
to Carly after she’s injected with the acid,
it causes blood to seep from her eyes,
giving her the appearance of having red eyes.
This happens after Jigsaw challenges her to
choose the needle that represents how much she
values a human life, with each one labeled to
a specific dollar amount. The needle with the
correct answer contains an antidote. This is
a reference back to the Nerve Gas House Game,
where players must compete to win antidotes
for a poison coursing through each of their
systems. There’s also a reference to the original
Saw; after hearing Jigsaw explain the rules,
the test-subjects check themselves to try to
see if they’ve been injected with anything.
“OK. Check yourself for marks. If he
injected us there could be marks.”
This is the same reaction Adam has
shortly after waking up in the bathroom.
ADAM: “Can you see any scars?”
LAWRENCE: “What?”
ADAM: “This is
what they do man. They kidnap you and drug
you. Before you know it you’re lying in
a bathtub and your kidneys are on eBay.”
As I mentioned, Carly’s look-alike shares a
similar fate in the present; she is found to
have been injected with hydrofluoric acid, the
same substance that Jigsaw would go onto use in
Saw 6 when Hydrofluoric Acid is injected
into William Easton during The Zoo Game.
TARA: “HF. What does that stand for?"
BRENT:  "Hydrofluoric aric.
This stuff will eat through
human flesh within seconds.”
The next trap of Kramer’s Barn Game was also
designed to drown us in Saw easter eggs. It
starts when Mitch and Anna go into a grain silo.
They are buried alive in corn kernels while Ryan
is stuck on the outside with the ability to
save them at his own personal expense. This
is the exact setup that Jigsaw would one day use
for The Pig Vat Trap from Saw 3. In The Pig Vat,
Jeff Denlon must decide whether or not to
save the judge that sentenced his son’s
killer from being drowned in pig guts at the
cost of burning the child’s old possessions.
There’s another reference to The Pig Vat Trap in
Jigsaw. Remember that music I was
jamming out to in my Saw 3 episode?
🎵 Music from Saw 3 🎵
For whatever reason, it’s not in the
Original Motion Picture Soundtrack for
Saw 3. It may be because the riff is very
similar to Eyes of the Insane by Slayer…
🎵 "The eyes, of the insane! On a demented campaign!" 🎵
So maybe they got a little nervous
about copyright, and decided not to
put that part in the score, but the good news
is there’s a more finished version in Jigsaw.
🎵 Cycle Trap - Charlie Clouser 🎵
It plays during the Cycle Trap, where it's
mostly drowned out by sound effects and dialogue,
but luckily it’s also in the end credits and
it did make it into the soundtrack this time.
I personally love when music has engine sounds
as part of the mix for some reason. NASCAR Type
Theatrical Hybrid Event is probably my favorite
Dethklok song and Horsepower is the song that
got me into Muzzy. Personally, I’m still holding
out for composer Charlie Clouser to play Knotfest.
But the Grain Silo Trap has more than just
one easter egg to offer, because after the
thing fills up with kernels, sharp objects
begin to rain down on the characters. The
abandoned barn is owned by Jill Tuck’s family.
That’s Jigsaw’s ex-wife if you don’t remember.
I’ve always wondered where John gets all the
weapons used to create his traps, and obviously
they come from many sources, it seems like many
of them could have been tools at the pig farm.
Among the items that fall are circular saw blades,
which are obviously a part of many traps,
most notably, the ending of Jeff’s Trial...
...knives, like those seen in
Saw 4’s Knife Chair trap...
...stakes, which play a vital
part in the Spike Trap from Saw 6…
...meat hooks, which are used
to hoist Bobby Dagen in Saw 7…
...and these mugs from the CZsWorld merch
sto-- wait! What is that doing th--
NEXT. TRAP. Actually before
we even get to the next room,
the dividers between these two rooms are
the exact ones from Gideon Meat Packing
Plant in Saw 3 and 4. Just thought
I’d point that out. But moving on,
the next room is the Human Blender, and this
iteration of it is powered by a motorcycle.
This is Mitch’s test, because he sold John’s
nephew a motorcycle one time and the brakes
didn’t work and the kid died. So his goal
in this trap is to reach for the brake that
will slow down this motorcycle. But that would
not be the last trap that John Kramer creates
where the subject has to reach into danger to
access the brake for an automobile. This pays
tribute to the horsepower trap, the setup that
proves fatal for Evan and his friends in Saw 7.
After Mitch stars in the world’s
scariest episode of Will It Blend?,
only Anna and uhh… part of Ryan remain. They
are subdued by John Kramer in a pig mask, and
they next wake up in the slaughter room. I think
this reference will be fairly obvious to Saw fans,
but they end up facing each other, each with an
ankle in a shackle on opposite sides of the room.
This scenario obviously calls back to Dr. Gordon
and Adam’s situation in The Bathroom Game.
“I just woke up here, just like you.”
But the traps seen in John Kramer’s original
Barn Game weren’t the only nostalgic references
to traps and setpieces of the Saw saga that
ran from 2004-2010. From Eleanor’s Studio,
to Nelson’s apartment there
are still plenty more Things
You Missed for us to explore.
We can’t let Jigsaw have
all the fun in this episode,
because this movie represents the
passing of the torch to a new disciple,
Logan Nelson. Early on, we see part of the reason
that Nelson wants to test Detective Halloran.
HUNT: “Why do you think he asked for you?”
HALLORAN: “We’re good friends. Put him away twice.”
Halloran was a corrupt cop, and at the end of
the film, Nelson gets him to admit all of his
wrongdoing by making him think that Jigsaw
is back and threatening him with the laser
collar. We actually see this payoff setup
by Eleanor as they examine the first victim,
she uses a singular laser cutter to
remove the bucket fastened to his head.
This does kind of raise some questions for
me, like if this things cuts through steel,
why doesn’t it cut all the way through the
building? But we’re not here to focus on that,
we’re here to talk about the flash drive
that Logan pulls out of his victim,
because it’s a reference to an earlier Saw movie.
You may remember when we talked about Saw 4,
where the recently passed away Jigsaw has
one final message for Detective Hoffman,
a tape that he covers in wax and swallows
for the pathologists to discover.
“Where is it?”
“It was in
his stomach.”
When Logan discovers the flash drive, he
has to cut it out of the plastic wrapping
that it’s encased in before putting
in a computer to listen to the audio.
“The games have begun again.
And they will not stop
until the sins against the
innocent are atoned for.”
When they get the results
of the voice analysis back,
Logan echoes one of Jigsaw’s
mottos: we speak for the dead.
“Just because someone is dead doesn’t
mean they can’t have a voice.”
“Give us enough time, we speak for the dead.”
It reminds me of the time Hoffman, who was
secretly Jigsaw’s successor at the time,
used John’s motto as part of his
speech at a police press conference.
“Throughout this ordeal, if
we’ve learned anything it’s that
human life is sacred. And we’ve learned
that every day, life should be cherished.”
And speaking of Hoffman, I’ve got a little
something for all you Hoffman is alive people.
There’s this scene where we see Hunt walking
through the police station, and in the background
there’s a board of wanted posters. If Hoffman was
alive, don’t you think Hoffman would be on here?
The only possibility really is that he’s alive,
but he’s in jail. Last time we saw him he was left
in The Bathroom to die. Now we know The Bathroom
was eventually discovered, because in Eleanor’s
studio there’s a replica of the hacksaws, which
were only ever used at The Bathroom. She also
has a replica of The Magnum Eyehole Trap, which
is in the room with the stairs that lead down
to the tunnel network where The Bathroom is.
Though it is possible that her recreation of
The Magnum Eyehole was based entirely off of
blueprints, but as far as the hacksaw goes,
I can’t imagine there would be blueprints for
that. Plus, even if there were for some reason,
she wouldn’t know they were significant unless
The Bathroom was discovered. My point is,
they probably did discover it, but Hoffman
was probably dead by the time they got there.
Other than the Magnum Eyehole, there are
replicas of many other iconic Saw traps
seen in Eleanor’s studio. There’s the Angel Trap,
which Detective Kerry was caught in during Saw 3…
The Water Cube that Special
Agent Strahm escaped in Saw 5…
The Reverse Bear Trap. This is the model
used against Amanda Young in
Saw, and Jill Tuck in Saw 7.
This might be the Razor Box from Saw 2...
It’s hard to tell for sure, but I feel like
we will see this location again in a future
film. The closet is a hidden door, which is
one of the recurring staples of the franchise,
and in the closet there’s a copy of the knife on
a chain from the Pound of Flesh Trap in Saw 6.
The inside of the closet is a shrine to Jigsaw,
and contains the actual newspaper headlines
seen throughout the seven past movies.
She also has an actual evidence marker just
like those used at the Jigsaw crime scenes
and what appears to be the black hair from
either Billy the Puppet or the pig masks.
At one point we actually get a better look
one of the newspapers that appeared in Saw 4,
but in that movie it was too blurry to actually
make out any of the text. It gives us a few more
Saw 4 easter eggs, but I think it makes
sense that I include them in this video,
since they’re only readable in Jigsaw. They are,
as usual, the writers of these articles being
named after the film crew of the fourth movie.
Ryan Hupponen was the art production coordinator,
Ashleigh Millar worked craft services in a rare
on screen appearance for the snack department and
Pauline Quong was a payroll accountant. And no,
that is not a racial stereotype joke. Look it up.
If you watched all the previous videos
in the Saw Things You Missed series,
you now know about a ton of those crew member
references across the series. Jigsaw does things
a bit differently though. There’s only one
such reference that I noticed, and it might
just be a total coincidence and I’m looking too
much into it, but in the cemetery scene there’s
a headstone labeled Armstrong. The biggest
difference between Jigsaw and the Saw movies
is the cinematography, and David Armstrong was the
cinematographer of Saws 1 through 6, and his style
was emulated in Saw 7. So to me, this tombstone
represents the death of the Armstrong look.
Or maybe they just filmed in an actual cemetery
and this happened to be there. If anyone lives in
Toronto, let me know. I mean I know people live
in Toronto obviously.... You know what I meant.
As far as references to other
stuff outside of the franchise,
there’s not much. Unless you want to call this
a reference to Wolverine or Freddy Krueger.
I’m not sure if I want to. But there does
seem to be one reference to an outside work,
but I can’t take credit for finding
it. So I’m not going to. Roll the clip.
“Apparently, critics have noted a
structural similarity between the
Saw films and French philosopher
Jean-Paul Sarcre’s famous play,
No Exit. So I watched all seven movies, read
No Exit, and immediately called bullsh**.
The connection was too tenuous. Then, Jigsaw
came out and when I saw this, I was like… huh.”
I’ll leave the link in the description
if you want to see his whole video,
but the basic gist of it is that this
play, No Exit is all about the torture
of confessing and being judged for one’s sins
by others. That’s the reason that Jigsaw in
this movie tortures his victims by asking
them to confess in front of the group as
opposed to the physical torture seen in the
previous entries. Maybe that’s the reason
that’s the reason Jigsaw’s credits bring back
the music from the Pig Vat Trap, because that’s
like the one other trap in the series that
focuses much more on psychological torture.
So Jigsaw redefines what it
means to experience torture,
and it would also redefine one of the long
running symbols of the franchise: The Pigs.
In a previous video, I mentioned that one of the
main characters in the movie, Detective Halloran,
doesn’t have a name other than… Halloran.
Well I’m proud to announce that I, CZsWorld,
have discovered Halloran’s first name. It’s Brad.
He’s a Brad. They say that finding this name is
as rare as finding Obama’s last name, so make
sure you like this video, just for that alone.
When Eleanor is putting together
the pathology report on the first
victim she discovers traces of pig fecal
matter found to contain Aujesky’s disease.
ELEANOR: “When swine get it, farmers have
to wipe out the entire sounder.”
In all of the other Saw movies, pigs represent the
rebirth of John’s followers. They are
metaphorically leaving their crimes,
or at least what Jigsaw perceives as crimes, in
a previous life. It seems like in Jigsaw though,
the meaning of the pig symbol has been expanded
to where pigs are now also a sign of compassion.
“Did you know that pigs are highly compassionate
animals? They show distress if they see
any other animal, including humans, suffering.”
John’s goal has always been to make
his subjects endure suffering open
their eyes and make them appreciate
their lives again. If they survive,
they become his followers, and wear the pig
masks to help spread John’s message to others.
That’s why it’s significant that the
barn game takes place in a pig farm.
Each of them represents one of his pigs,
they can either win and become his followers,
or lose and be slaughtered. The final room, which
was to be their final test, is the slaughter room.
But throughout the game he doesn’t
actually have followers yet,
so he’s seen wearing the pig mask
himself during the past storyline.
In the present storyline, it appears that
John Kramer, or one of his disciples, is back
again holding new games, and at the end of the
movie Logan and Eleanor go to hunt him down.
During these scenes, Eleanor is wearing
a leopard print jacket and leopards are
a natural predator of many wetland hogs and
boar. In other words… leopards hunt pigs.
And although that was Eleanor’s intention,
she ends up having to run from the pig farm,
where she’s picked up by a driver. We never see
who it is, but she looks kind of distressed and
confused when she sees the person. Could it be
Dr. Gordon? Daniel? Corbett? Only time will tell.
“Literally. Cause I’m building
a time machine to find out.”
Oh my God that’s a terrible idea!
So we eventually come to learn that
Logan Nelson was actually Jigsaw’s
apprentice all along, and we was putting
himself in the game at the end there,
just as John did, just as Amanda
did and just as Hoffman did.
But how did he make this whole thing
work? Let’s look back at it. There
was a lot of background work required by
Nelson, such as sneaking back into St.
Peter’s Hospital to kidnap Edgar Munsen,
digging up John Kramer’s grave and
depositing the bodies of his recreated game
throughout the city for Brad Halloran to find.
I guess we are to believe that
he just stays up and does all
this stuff overnight based on what
he tells his daughter’s babysitter.
“I’m sorry I have to stay so late again Judy.”
There’s also a clue about him being
connected to Jigsaw in his study,
where you can spot one of those little
Buddhist figures in his bedroom, just like
the ones first seen at John Kramer’s deathbed
among other appearances throughout the series.
When Brad looks into Logan Nelson’s
bio on the Veterans Affairs database,
there’s a lot of background information
about his time during and after
serving in the Army. There’s a lot to cover here
that helps explain why he never helped Jigsaw
during Saw saga. If you’re interested, I made
a whole video on The History of Logan Nelson.
When Eleanor shows him the studio, they’re
being tailed by Hunt, who I can already tell
is a better evidence photographer than Adam, cause
he doesn’t blatantly use the flash in a dark room.
But Logan was still able to later
convince Hunt that Brad Halloran
was setting him up. But by the time Hunt
gives his people the order to arrest Brad,
he’s already tailing Logan and Eleanor. They end
up essentially leading him into his own tomb.
I noticed that the situation is very similar
to what Hoffman does to Peter Strahm in Saw 5.
Actually, it’s not very similar, it's exactly
the same. He makes J Jonah Erickson suspicious
of Strahm, he knows Strahm is following him
and he leads him right into his final trap.
Brad finds himself in the Slaughter Room, where
he and Logan both appear to be imprisoned by
these collars, and Logan uses an old Saw trick
to get him to make his confession. The lasers
on Logan’s collar are fake, and so is the blood
that spurts out when the lasers zero in on him.
We’ve seen Adam do it, we’ve seen Jigsaw do it,
we’ve seen Daniel Matthews do it, we’ve seen Eric
Matthews do it and now we would see Logan Nelson
play dead to get the upper hand on his opponent.
As I mentioned way back at the beginning,
after a confession we see the Brad flower
bloom into eight pedals as we come to
the end of the eighth movie. I have got.
To get. A slidey. Door like that.
So I can game over all my guests.
“I speak for the dead.”
Or that.
Alright, we’ve done them all. Click the playlist
on the left to see Things You Missed in every
single Saw film. And we’re only a week away
from a new Saw movie being released. So if
you want to see everything you might have missed
in Spiral then remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one. Assuming, we both survive.